[Music]
avanti dean was a fascist philosopher of
the 20s 30s and 40s but he's probably
the most important example of how old
ideas can be brought back in a 21st
century or in a postmodern context
aleem had three very important ideas the
first was that social advancement was
impossible because the political system
the social system is like a body so
you're a cell you're an embryo you're
organ you have a place in this larger
body and freedom means knowing your
place that's what freedom means a second
idea that he had is that democracy is a
ritual so we can vote but we only vote
in order to affirm our collective
support for a leader the leader is not
legitimated by our votes or chosen by
our votes the voting is just a ritual by
which we collectively every couple of
years endorse a leader who has emerged
from some other place from some he mean
in fascism leader is some kind of hero
who emerges from fiction or emerges from
myth the third idea alene had which is
very useful is that the factual world
doesn't count it's not real aleem says
that God created the world but that was
a mistake
the world was a kind of aborted process
it's the world is a horrifying thing
because it's full of this and that and
the other thing what we call facts and
those facts can't be unified into some
kind of larger whole so the world is
actually horrifying and those facts are
disgusting and of no value whatsoever so
if you're if you were Vladimir Putin and
you're governing as the head of an
oligarchical clan it's very comfortable
to be able to say well look freedom
consists in knowing your place in
society there's no possibility for
social advance if you're Vladimir Putin
and you don't have serious democracy or
you don't want to have it it's very
comfortable to do as the in fact has
done it's very comfortable to transform
elections into a kind of ritual and
likewise if you can't have the rule of
law and if Russians are basically stuck
in a certain place economically and
politically the idea that the world is
not factual that the world is just
subjective that it's just a matter of
this opinion that opinion the other
opinion is very comfortable and Elina
adds the even more comfortable
conclusion that the only true thing is
Russian nationalism the only hope to
bring the whole world together is that
somehow Russia which is an innocent
victim of the rest of the world will
somehow restore itself in some
totalitarian form and then bring order
back to the world so interestingly it's
not the only thing which is going on but
interestingly these kinds of ideas help
mr. Putin as he consolidates a certain
kind of authoritarianism by spectacle at
home and also help him as he broadcasts
it abroad as the the fundamental way
that Russia works in American politics
is by transmitting the idea that
nothing's real so it's true that the
Russians did support Trump it's true
that there were all kinds of very
specific interventions in the election
2016 but the fundamental idea is to take
new technology and transmit this old
idea that we can't really trust
ourselves that there aren't really facts
out there in the world the only thing
that really matters is our preferences
or really our biases or really are our
hatreds and this was so manifest in 2016
because it's it's it's important that
the Russians persuaded us of various
things that weren't true
but what's more important is that we
never thought that this could be
happening as a result of action by some
other country we were entirely caught in
our own little subjective American
reality of us and them we're the friends
and the enemies were all Americans we
couldn't break out into any kind of
larger world of actuality the Russians
precisely helped him us into a little
national emotional world to the point
where we couldn't even see what was
happening and a lot of us are still
having a lot of trouble seen what was
what was happening so what what these
kinds of the interesting marriage for me
is old ideas fascist ideas in fact in a
new world a new world where it's it's
not that mr. Putin or for that matter
mr. Trump wants us all to our uniforms
in march in the streets or even to have
large-scale wars for territory that's
not what's going on but what the fascist
ideas do with the new technology is they
drive us into a situation where we think
the real stakes of politics are all
emotional and all about enemies usually
enemies at home where we get ourselves
all worked up about things whether we
like the government
but somehow we never leave our couch
while we're while we're doing it where
we leave all of our energy right in
front of the screen basically and don't
get and don't actually get out and vote
or organize or or think creatively about
what policy might look like and and the
result is that we end up you know we end
up consolidating this kind of oligarchy
with some racial overtones which is what
America and Russia currently have in
common
you